[Music]
the Bosnian capital Sarajevo has been a
melting pot of Muslims Jews and Catholic
and Orthodox Christians for centuries
the old town dotted with markets and
courtyards was designed by the Turks 600
years ago and the Ottoman influence is
also evident in the local cuisine as
served up by this restaurant Satch amina
savage has been working here for 15
years it's the place to come for classic
Bosnian Brubeck my name is Amina Savage
I'm born in Serbia but I'm living in
Bosnia and Herzegovina I am working to
be such the name the shop and we are
traditional way and we are making the
pie Kovac is baked pastry with various
fillings the snack originated in Turkey
in addition to serving Bullock Amina
also has a hand in making it
the process involves gracefully tossing
the dough back and forth until it's just
thin enough my friend told me to come
here then I tried to learn how to make
it how to make it how to sell turd what
meats what cheese or spinach potato once
those fillings have been added the dough
is rolled into long thin sausages and
placed in a spiral
this man has an extremely demanding job
he's responsible for keeping the
charcoal fired ovens alight the heat is
so relentless that he and his colleagues
change over shifts after just four and a
half hours we are making on the fire but
it's a traditional way our father or
mother they make it like this on the
fire it's very hot here ten minutes in
the oven and they're done the Berlocq is
served with yogurt sauce and is washed
down with tea or a fresh yogurt drink
such is a place that brings hungry
locals and tourists together an
incredible three-thousand portions a day
are served up here
it is the fresh it is a handmade it and
it is made it by the recipe of the
ethnic restaurant here and Boston women
what they do here
like like home they do it like home like
our mothers they're good except here you
pay one year or 50 for a portion the
Burke is so popular among locals that
many take it away to eat at home
[Music]